du jour appelle la discussion après
engagement de la procédure accélérée de
la proposition de loi adoptée par le
Sénat visant à renforcer
l'accompagnement des élus locaux dans la
mise en oeuvre de la lutte contre
l'artificialisation des sols la parole
est à Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre
de la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires
madame la Présidente
messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
suis très heureux de vous retrouver
ce matin dans cette émission pour
l'examen de cette proposition qui vise à
renforcer la compagnement des élus
locaux dans la mise en œuvre de la lutte
contre l'artificialisation des sols
peu de sujets concentre finalement
autant d'enjeux
lutter contre l'artificialisation des
sols
c'est
lutter contre les régions de la
biodiversité
la première cause
lutter contre l'artificialisation des
sols
c'est lutter contre le dérèglement du
cycle de l'eau qui fait que un seul
artificialisé ne joue plus son rôle ne
permet pas la phréatique de se remplir
et accélère les phénomènes de
ruissellement
lutter contre l'artificialisation des
sols c'est s'inscrire dans un combat
contre le dérèglement climatique
puisqu'un seul artificialisé ne stocke
pas de CO2
lutter contre l'artificialisation des
sols s'est préserver la souveraineté de
notre pays
en faisant précisément en sorte que nous
puissions conserver des espaces pour
notre agriculture pour notre
souveraineté alimentaire
dans un contexte où on voudrait lui
faire porter beaucoup de choses mais où
la réalité est différente depuis 1981 ce
sont
deux millions d'hectares qui ont été
artificialisés dit autrement nous avons
plus artificialisé notre pays en 50 ans
qu'en 500 ans et ça n'est pas corrélé à
une hausse de la population nous
l'avonsage d'attentage fait que nos
voisins quand on regarde le nombre de
mètres carrés artificialisé rapporté par
habitant
face à cette urgence
le Parlement votre assemblée et le Sénat
ont adopté une trajectoire de 0
artificialisation nette dans le cadre de
la loi climat et résilience avec un
double engagement
divisé par deux
sur la décennie dans laquelle nous
sommes d'ici 2031 la consommation
d'espaces naturels agricoles et
forestiers
ce qui veut dire prolongé une baisse
déjà observée de la consommation
d'espaces naturels avec un effort
supplémentaire pour s’en tenir un
objectif moyen de consommation de
l'ordre de 12500 hectares par an
et je veux souligner que la loi n'a pas
créé une rupture
dans les pratiques d'aménagement elle
amplifie une tendance et demande un
effort supplémentaire mais un effort
limité
la marge d'après ce sera bien celle qui
consistera à partir de 2050 dans 30 ans
de parvenir à un usage des sols de 0
artificialisation nette donc à faire le
sol d'entre les surfaces nouvellement
artificialisées les surfaces rendues à
la nature mais j'ai parfois l'impression
à la lumière de certains débats que
certains font comme si cet objectif
était déjà entrés en vigueur
je précise aussi que nous ne sommes pas
seuls que bon nombre de nos partenaires
européens ont d'ores et déjà adopter des
mesures pour limiter cet
artificialisation et que cet objectif de
l'horizon 2050 d'une 0 artificialisation
nette
et partager
notre objectif constant depuis le début
c'est garantir l'application et le
respect de cette trajectoire à la fois
parce qu'elle est issue d'un vote de la
représentation nationale un vote large
et garantir l'application le respect de
cette trajectoire parce qu'elle est
indispensable pour toutes les raisons
que je viens d'évoquer mais le faire en
privilégiant le dialogue et la
concertation avec les élus locaux vous
le savez c'est l'esprit que nous avons
suivi depuis le début et en particulier
lors du premier passage de ce texte
souhaité par le Sénat pour défendre les
mesures de bon sens et de facilitation
avec
dans le même temps
la volonté que cette assemblée puisse
éviter des dispositions qui videraient
de leur substance
la trajectoire de sobriété foncière de
ce point de vue le texte qui a été voté
au Sénat nous paraît améliorable
trop de dispositions incluses viennent
compromettre la crédibilité de cette
trajectoire nous nous sommes efforcés
avant que ce texte ne commence son
examen à l'Assemblée nationale de mener
de nouvelles concertations approfondie
avec les associations d'élus en
particulier avec l'Association des
maires de France pour tenter de trouver
le chemin du consensus dans notre pays a
besoin sur cette question
je tiens à rappeler les mesures de bon
sens de facilitation avec lesquelles
nous sommes en accord depuis le début
mais qui nécessite que nous puissions
remettre sur le métier l'ouvrage
législatif d'abord la prise en compte de
la renaturation avant 2031 ensuite la
mise en place de nouveaux outils
pour aider les communes à pouvoir mieux
maîtriser les projets dans cette même
décennie Azelle aide d'une extension du
droit de préemption ou grâce à la mise
en place de périmètre de sursis est
statué communiquer les données pour que
les communes puissent
mieux mesurer les effets de
l'artificialisation et réagir
donner la possibilité aux communes
littoral d'anticiper le recul du trait
de côte et puis deux dispositions
cruciales dans ces discussions
législatives la prise en compte des
grands projets nationaux et le principe
d'une garantie rurale
la première difficulté que certains
grands projets de l'État je pense à des
infrastructures majeures comme le canal
senor Europe consomme beaucoup d'espace
à l'échelle d'une région et de très
nombreuses demandes convergent pour
compter à part ces grands projets j'y
suis favorable à la condition que cela
ne remette pas en cause
l'objectif de réduction de 50 % de
consommation d'espace naturel agricoles
et forestiers pour tout cela il me
semble nécessaire que cette liste de
grands projets reste définie par l'État
qu'une péréquation entre les régions
permet globalement de s'assurer du
respect de l'objectif et puis j'allais
dire à l'autre bout du spectre
il convient en ce qui concerne la
garantie rurale que les communes
puissent bénéficier
d'une sorte
d'espérance ou de droits au projet
le principe de la garantie rurale est
partagé par le gouvernement la question
qui se posera ici ce sera la manière
dont elle doit être ciblée notamment
pour faire en sorte qu'elle bénéficie de
manière effective aux communes rurales
et aux communes
peu dense de manière générale
l'examen du texte en commission a permis
de rééquilibrer le texte qui était
parvenu du Sénat en revoyant au décret
les dispositions qui relevaient du
réglementaire afin de pouvoir centrer
nos discussions sur les dispositions qui
relèvent strictement du domaine de la
loi et pour lesquels nous avons besoin
d'un texte si nous considérons que le
zan est perfectible
mesdames et messieurs les députés
le texte issu de la commission est un
texte de compromis qui permet à la fois
d'adopter les dispositions et les
ambitions de la loi climat résilience
mais d'essayer de mieux tenir compte de
la réalité des territoires et des
remontées de terrain que nous avons eu
parvenir à un consensus sur un sujet
aussi ambitieux c'est en rien un
lancement c'est assumer l'idée qu'une
ambition écologique forte doit passer
par une capacité à entraîner la majeure
partie de nos concitoyens nos
territoires ça va être toute l'ambition
des heures qui nous attendent et du
chemin que nous avons à construire avec
un objectif qui est de ne pas quitter
cette hémicycle sans accord parce que
l'enjeu c'est bien d'avoir un dispositif
qui soit opérant avant le milieu du mois
de juillet avec une CMP conclusive qui
permettent de faire en sorte de répondre
aux attentes de ces milliers de maire
partout sur le territoire qui nous
demandent quelques assouplissements et
qui ont été relayés par la Haute
Assemblée pour lesquelles nous allons
faire en sorte de trouver une réponse
appropriée merci beaucoup pour votre
attention et je me réjouis de ces débats
qui commencent
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Monsieur Bastien Marchi rapporteur de
la commission des affaires économiques
et pour 5 minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre
monsieur le rapporteur pour avis chers
collègues
depuis plusieurs décennies la France
construit chaque année l'équivalent de 2
à 3 fois la ville de Paris sur ses
espaces naturels ça fait de nous le plus
mauvais élève européen en termes de
sobriété foncière
à titre de comparaison nous avons
consommé 15% de terre en plus que
l'Allemagne qui est pourtant bien plus
peuplé 57% de plus que le Royaume-Uni
qui a une population semblable
on pourrait se dire et alors
mais ce serait renié le réchauffement
climatique et la capacité qu'on au sol à
capter le CO2 ce serait aussi ne pas
tenir compte de l'érosion de la
biodiversité ou de la perturbation du
cycle de l'eau que l'artificialisation
implique sans oublier que ce sont nos
terres qui sont les garantes de notre
souveraineté alimentaire
alors quand il y a deux ans notre
Assemblée a voté la loi climat et une
trajectoire de réduction de
l'artificialisation elle a fait preuve
d'un esprit de responsabilité
il ne s'agit pas aujourd'hui de revenir
sur ses ambitions qui ne saurai que
demeurer intact
nous voilà donc un cap clair
diminué par deux la consommation des
espaces naturels agricoles et forestiers
sur les 10 prochaines années et aboutir
à ce qu'on appelle désormais le zéro
artificialisation nette à horizon 2050
mais des questions se posent
comment garantir que les grands projets
de demain aboutissent comment mieux
accompagner les communes en particulier
rurales pour atteindre ses objectifs en
bref comment faire pour construire mieux
ne soit pas synonyme de ne plus
construire
c'est tout l'enjeu de ce texte d'y
répondre en permettant de décliner ses
objectifs au sein des territoires car ce
sont bien eux qui sont compétents pour
le faire et en sont les chevilles
ouvrières dans leur document d'urbanisme
que sont les stradettes Scott pluie pas
Duke et autres dont nous parlerons
beaucoup aujourd'hui dans nos débats
nombre de collectivités locales ont pu
faire part de leur crainte à la fois de
ne plus pouvoir se développer mais aussi
que la ruralité soit la grande oubliée
que les bons élèves soient pénalisés ou
encore d'un déficit d'ingénierie qui ne
leur permettrait pas de faire face au
coût et à l'expertise qu'implique la
mise en oeuvre de ces objectifs
c'est pour répondre à ces alertes que le
ministre a pris la décision de suspendre
les décrets d'application s'ouvrait
alors une période de réflexion et de
concertation avec l'ensemble des acteurs
concernés que nous avons rencontrés
auditionné au premier rang desquels les
associations d'élus évidemment mais
aussi les associations environnementales
nos agriculteurs nos promoteurs acteurs
du logement du monde économique et plus
globalement tous ceux qui sont concernés
par ces objectifs ambitieux que nous
portons
alors à nous de faire en sorte qu'avec
ce texte il soit entendu et comme
rapporteur j'aimerais vous partager les
trois grands principes qui ont guidé mes
travaux
d'abord maintenir le cap des ambitions
environnementales voulues par la
Convention citoyenne pour le climat
lorsqu'elle nous inspirait le texte du
22 août 2021 dernier
la protection des sols constituent en
effet l'un des piliers de la transition
environnementale et leur n'est plus à
revenir sur de telles objectifs
seulement deux ans après les avoir
adoptés et alors même qui commence
seulement à être décliné
ensuite tenir compte de la particularité
française je veux parler de ces villages
et de ces paysages auxquels nous sommes
tous attachés en veillant à la justice
territoriale dans la répartition des
droits à construire ce n'est qu'un si en
confiance et dans le respect de la
liberté des élus locaux que nous y
parviendrons et c'est pourquoi il vous
sera proposé de consacrer une garantie
rurale un sursis à statué ou encore
d'accompagner la mise en oeuvre de
projets d'intérêts régionaux ou
intercommunaux
enfin pour la transition
environnementale et pour notre
souveraineté garantir la réalisation des
grands projets d'envergure national
qui justifie de par leur objet et leur
ampleur que l'effort en découlant soit
solidairement partagé sans que cela ne
se fasse au dépend du cap-fixé
le travail que nous avons mené
conjointement en commission des affaires
économiques s'inscrit dans cette logique
et j'appelle de mes vœux qu'il en soit
également assis dans le cadre de nos
débats
alors chers collègues
à ceux qui s'inquiéteraient pour
l'atteinte de nos objectifs
environnementaux
je veux dire que nos ambitions sont
intactes et qu'ils sont bel et bien
respectés à ceux qui redouteraient le
blocage des projets décisifs pour
l'avenir de notre pays je veux dire
qu'ils sont ici sécurisés et à ceux qui
craindraient pour le développement des
communes rurales je veux dire que nous
l'avons ici garanti
la proposition de loi telle que nous
l'avons adopté en commission et qui vous
est ici présenté respecte ces grands
équilibres il nous appartient désormais
collectivement de les préserver je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Lionel cosse
rapporteur pour avis de la commission du
développement durable et l'aménagement
des territoires et pour 5 minutes
merci Madame le présidente monsieur le
ministre de Monsieur les présidents de
commission monsieur le rapporteur cher
Bastien chers collègues la proposition
de loi visa à renforcer les élus locaux
dans la mise en œuvre de la lutte contre
l'artificialisation que nous examinons à
partir de ce matin s'inscrit dans la
trajectoire que nous sommes fixés
concernés à sobriété foncière
je tiens à vous rappeler que en 2011 la
Commission européenne a inscrit dans sa
feuille de route la sobriété foncière en
particulier le zinc en 2050 comme étant
un objectif pour tous les les États
membres en 2016 la loi biodiversité a
transférer la compétence sobriété
foncière aux régions à travers les
stradettes et en fait en 2021 dans la
loi climat et résilience nous avons
revalider ces objectifs et nous avons
commencé à définir un premier calendrier
calendrier basé sur une décennale 2021
2031 avec un objectif comme ça vient
d'être dit de diviser par deux la
consommation des Hénaf que nous avons je
dirais consommer entre 2011 et 2021
entre 2011 et 2021 nous avons consommé
250 000 hectares ce qui veut dire
quasiment un petit peu plus de deux fois
la ville de Paris par an il est donc
demandé aujourd'hui soit décennale en
cours donc consommer 125 000 c'est à
dire encore un petit peu plus d'une fois
la ville de Paris par an donc ce projet
de loi s'inscrit dans les modalités des
déclinaisons la territorialisation afin
d'atteindre ses objectifs je tiens à
rappeler si on prend des horaires un
petit peu plus longue que depuis 1982
l'artifisation des sols augmentait de
72% dans notre pays tandis que la
population est même augmentée de
19%. on voit bien donc aujourd'hui qu'en
matière d'aménagement du territoire nous
devons et nous avons la responsabilité
nous poser des questions pour les années
à venir surtout que l'artification des
sols et la première cause de perte de
biodiversité
alors aujourd'hui cette PPL qui est bien
du Sénat qui a été travaillé par deux
commissions la commission Développement
Durable aménagement du territoire et la
commission des affaires économiques
permet d'apporter de nouveaux outils au
décideurs locaux et en particulier aux
élus locaux quel que soit leur niveau
commune rural commune urbaine
département région Scott
intercommunalité c'est le résultat d'un
long travail élaboré avec le Sénat bien
entendu le gouvernement merci Monsieur
le Ministre les associations d'élus et
aussi l'assemblée je remercie tous mes
collègues parlementaires qui se sont
depuis de nombreuses années nombreux
mois mobilisés sur ce sujet
il a il a résulte un équilibre un
équilibre nécessaire mais je tiens à
vous le dire qu'il ne sera pas une fin
en soi
la trajectoire d'USA pour 2050
nécessitera d'autres projets de loi ou
propositions de loi ne serait-ce pour
préparer la deuxième décennale 2031 2041
à quelle nous devrons un moment le
moment venu ici débattre
chers collègues plutôt nous protégerons
nos sols et plus grand de sera notre
adaptation face aux risques et aux
crises écologiques à venir il ne s'agit
pas de figer nos territoires mais de les
transformer de les embellir en gérant au
mieux l'existant
je vous le dis avec conviction il ne
suffit pas de voir
il suffit de voir les vides qui
aujourd'hui s'inscrivent dans cette
trajectoire on peut penser aux petites
villes de demain pour voir que ces
enjeux peuvent être réalisés
et peut se le dire aussi le zéro
artificiel ne veut pas dire le zéro
construction
chers collègues notre responsabilité
législateur nous impose d'accompagner
nos territoires il ne serait pas sérieux
de faire croire aux élus locaux que la
trajectoire fixée et les objectifs de
sobriété foncière pourrait être remis à
plus tard je vous invite donc à aborder
ce débat avec sérieux et détermination
merci
merci monsieur le rapporteur
j'ai reçu de Monsieur Marc Le Fur une
motion de Roger préalable déposé en
application de l'article 91 alinéa 5 du
règlement la parole est à Monsieur Marc
Le Fur et pour une durée de 15 minutes
maximum
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues
cette motion de rejet porte très
explicitement contre le principe même du
SAN zéro artificialisation nette et
contre l'idéologie sous-jacente qui le
sous-tend
le texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
apporte certes des améliorations mais là
ce ne remet pas en cause l'essentiel du
dispositif que je juge contraires aux
intérêts de nos territoires
derrière ce sigle se cache un dispositif
que nos élus locaux découvrent
effrayés et dont il mesure déjà les
incidences redoutables pour leur commune
si chacun comprend la nécessité de la
sobriété il faut bien admettre que le
zan nous fait passer dans un système de
rationnement le but est d'arriver en
2050 vous l'avez dit monsieur le
ministre à zéro artificialisation nette
c'est-à-dire à la glaciation notre
territoire mais dès maintenant ceci a
des incidences tout à fait redoutables
sur la capacité de construire
quelle est la demande initiale qui nous
a amené aux ânes c'est la protection de
la terre agricole demande légitime
mais aujourd'hui ce qui menace l'élevage
certains d'entre nous connaissent bien
cette filière agricole dans ma région ou
dans d'autres ce n'est ni le logement ni
l’industrie c'est la végétalisation la
transformation d'exploitation d'élevage
notamment laitiers en culture quand ce
n'est pas quand ce n'est pas en jachère
comme trop souvent une intention
vertueuse quand la protection de la
terre agricole se transforme en monstre
technocratique
nous aurons les dispositions les plus
exigeantes d'Europe alors que nous
disposons d'espace nous avons l'une des
densités les plus basses des grands pays
européens avec 117 habitants en
kilomètres carrés je rappelle que
l'Allemagne compte 239 habitants au
kilomètre carré le double la
Grande-Bretagne 277 plus du double
l'Italie de sang et je ne parle pas des
Pays-Bas avec 519 habitants km2 l'un des
avantages relatifs de la France en
Europe c'est de disposer d'espace un tel
degré d'exigence voulu par le zan aurait
pu s'imaginer et je crois qu'il aurait
été pertinent s'il n'avait concerné que
les métropoles et leur périphérie
c'est-à-dire la même ou le problème de
l'excès de consommation d'espace s'est
posé et là
au nom d'un principe jacobin absurde la
même règle va s'appliquer à la Lozère à
l'Île-de-France vont être concernés la
Haute-Loire le Cantal la Manche et bien
des départements qui n'ont pas été
atteints par le phénomène métropolitain
l'avantage relatif du monde rural c'est
son espace lui inter lui interdire
l'utilisation de cet espace c'est lui
interdire tout développement
c'est lui faire perdre son attractivité
quand on est dans le monde rural on est
plus loin que les urbains pour un
certain nombre de commerces pour un
certain nombre de services on est obligé
d'utiliser un système de transport plus
coûteux parce qu'on est parfois plus
loin de son emploi il n'en demeure pas
moins qu'on peut disposer d'espace plus
grand plus libre et cet avantage relatif
vous allez le faire disparaître c'est
bien pour cela que le zan est ruraliste
il ne faudrait pas pleurer de même
monsieur le ministre sur la fermeture
des écoles faute d'enfants puisqu'on
aura interdit à leurs parents de
s'installer de construire de bâtir dans
la commune qui est la leur il faudra
assumer toutes ses conséquences monsieur
le ministre demain
et tous les effets pervers que nous
craignons lors du débat que nous avions
mis en avant lors du débat législatif
sur la loi climat voient désormais le
jour concrètement prenez l'exemple de la
nécessaire réindustrialisation et là on
est en pleine injonction contradictoire
mes chers collègues le président de la
République nous dit qu'il faut
réindustrialiser le pays jihader et
j'imagine ne pas être le seul dans cette
enceinte cette industrialisation est
indispensable il faut reconquérir notre
souveraineté industrielle 10% de notre
bise notre pipe simplement est liée à
l'industrie contre 20% en Allemagne 15%
en Italie verte ou par verte notre
industrie a besoin de foncier
je viens d'un territoire l'un des rares
en France qui a su préserver la pointe
industriel où le secteur secondaire a vu
ses effectifs s'accroître ou la
population avril hier s'est développée
on a des arguments qui a permis la
création de ces emplois industriels
c'est l'existence de zone d'activité
spacieuse capable d'accueillir des sites
industriels conséquents on n'installe
pas une usine comme on installe des
bureaux d'assurance il faut de l'espace
on peut pas se mettre à côté
immédiatement des voisins voilà quelques
éléments de bon sens qui semble-t-il en
t'échapper à certains mais les effets de
rationnement fonciers commencent à se
faire sentir dès aujourd'hui un cas
récemment défrayé la conique la
chronique qui se trouve qui se passe
dans le département d'Ille-et-Vilaine
les projets d'usine Bridor à Liffré
c'était un projet qui permettait la
création de 500 emplois
c'était dû à l'initiative d'un créateur
véritable capitaine d'industrie lui
duffe auquel je souhaite rendre hommage
ici aujourd'hui
ce projet est à l'abandon multiplicité
de contraintes administratives
difficultés liées à l'espace c'était un
projet sur 21 hectares je ne suis pas
sûr qu'on puisse trouver en Bretagne ou
dans d'autres régions des capacités pour
accueillir un tel projet aujourd'hui
avec les réglementations que vous que
vous nous imposez
au-delà des industries se pose également
la question des bâtiments agricoles
certaines régions de rurales attirent
des populations ne serait-ce parce qu'on
dit que parce qu'on y trouve du travail
encore faut-il des logements le coût du
logement n'a cessé de se renchérir
naguère une population aux revenus
moyens voire modeste parvenait en
faisant des efforts à accéder à la
propriété au moins dans des petites
villes et dans des zones rurales ce
n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui l'une des
raisons c'est la montée du prix du
foncier et le zan en rendant
artificiellement rare le foncier
constructible va encore renchérir le
coût de la construction combien de
maires ne nous ont-ils pas dit chez moi
je peux construire j'ai des espaces je
préfère un hectare de maïs 7 ou 800 qui
vont accueillir des familles et ou des
enfants pourront grandir et bien ils ne
pourront plus le faire demain comment le
gouvernement et la majorité peut-il être
aussi sourd devant les besoins qui
expriment la population la population
française je sais que ça ne plaît pas de
ce côté-ci du périphérique aspire
l'accession à la propriété et aspire à
la maison individuelle tous les sondages
le confirment c'est l'aspiration de nos
concitoyens et cette aspiration n'a
cessé de croître ces dernières années du
fait des effets du covid le covid a
renforcer le besoin de bulles en quelque
sorte de protection que permet la maison
individuelle après l'épisode du covid ça
c'est considérablement renforcer et pour
la maison individuelle que vous décriez
je me dois de rappeler que les
équipements que vous souhaitez voir se
développer dans le sens du respect de
l'environnement se font plus facilement
en maison individuelle le branchement de
la voiture électrique ou hybride se fait
plus facilement en maison individuelle
quand l'autisme quand que dans des
immeubles l'implantation de pompe à
chaleur se fait plus facilement dans les
maisons individuelles le compostage
nécessaire et de bon sens se fait plus
facilement dans une maison individuelle
disposant de jardin
logement toujours il nous faut du
logement social
tout le monde en convient
or au vu des textes en débat le logement
social ne bénéficiera pas a priori
d'aucune de bénéficiera a priori
d'aucune dérogation permettant
d'échapper aux ânes
les logements social sera soumis en même
contrainte au même contrainte
le zan va donc priver des logements
sociaux dont nous avons besoin nous
avons d'autant plus besoin des logements
sociaux que le pouvoir d'achat ne
concitoyens s'est effondré c'est
partiellement dû à votre politique
monsieur le ministre pardonnez-moi de
vous le redire nous avons d'autant plus
besoin de logements sociaux que le prix
des logements et le prix de l'accession
à la propriété c'est accru c'est ça la
réalité c'est ça la parole s'il vous
plaît et oui oui
merci madame la Présidente
la population la population aspire à
arriver dans un certain nombre de zones
pour lesquelles elle sollicitent des
logements sociaux qui aujourd'hui ne
sont pas possible demain ne pourront
plus être construit
également
jusqu'à il y a peu au moins dans les
secteurs ruraux les petites villes un
certain nombre de résidents de logements
sociaux l'équité pour accéder à la
propriété c'était le parcours
résidentiel ce parcours résidentiel
n'est plus possible aujourd'hui du fait
de la montée du prix de l'accession à la
propriété qui était possible encore hier
comment vont faire les communes qui
n'ont pas encore atteint la norme la loi
srue et qui ne pourrait pas construire
elles vont être soumises à pleine
injonction contradictoire on exigera
d'elle la construction est la loi et
Serru et en les soumettra à la menthe si
elle ne le font pas et pour autant les
logements sociaux ne bénéficieront pas
de la dérogation du zan alors au moins
là-dessus on devrait pouvoir évoluer
avec deux ans nous allons rentrer dans
les arcanes technocratiques et
administratives
ubuesque et absurde nombre de communes
sont des insoumises à des contraintes
multiples la loi montagne la loi
littorale la réglementation sur les
zones humides la réglementation sur les
zones hondables quand un maire se voit
accumulé toutes ces difficultés ben il
lui est difficile voir impossible de
construire avec le zanne le maire l'élu
qui naguère pouvait destiner sa ville
dans les 20 ou 30 ans c'était toute la
noblesse de cette mission et bien cette
noblesse lui est désormais interdite il
ne sera plus que l'exécutant du zan
cette arbitre également les arbitrages
multiples que l'on va exiger des mers et
des élus vont occasionner des
difficultés des querelles au sein des
intercommunalités pour se partager le
petit élément de rationnement possible
ça va poser aussi des problèmes en droit
privé puisque aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de terrains sont constructibles
elles ne seront plus de mains un
président d'intercommunalité me disait
que plus de 80% de ces territoires
aujourd'hui constructibles ne seront pas
demain c'est-à-dire que des gens vont
perdre un patrimoine ils iront
s'adresser aux maires qui leur dira je
n'y peux rien il viendront vous voir
Monsieur le Ministre et vous leur direz
les idéologies que vous nous développez
régulièrement il n'empêche que ces
gens-là auront perdu de l'argent et
auront perdu des éléments de patrimoine
bon courage au début qui devront
expliquer tout ça
comme si toujours en multiplie les
règles et comme toujours quand on a des
règles on cherche des exceptions d'où
les grands projets nationaux et
qu'est-ce qui aura dans les grands
projets nationaux qui dérogeront aux
ânes alors j'ai vu dans les gazettes
monsieur le ministre que vous vous
currez les avec votre collègue le maire
l'indépendant l'industrie l'autre
défendant l'idéologie chacun aura
compris les rôles de chacun j'espère et
vous savez l'affection de vos portes
nous avons fait des campagnes ensemble
monsieur le ministre j'espère que vous
ne gagnerez pas ces arbitrages et qu'au
contraire la capacité de construire
l'industrie sera toujours possible
ces arbitrages vont être très pénibles
je prends je prends un cas très concret
puisqu'on va déroger par exemple pour
les zones d'atterrages des câbles
sous-marins pour les éoliennes alors
c'est vrai que les éoliennes elles ont
droit à tout toutes les exceptions tous
les privilèges tous les avantages pour
les éoliennes en terre et en mer et là
ça sera possible paraît-il alors que ce
ne sera pas possible pour un hôpital ça
ne sera pas possible de déroger un des
ânes pour un hôpital ce ne sera ce sera
possible pour des prisons nous dit-on
mais pas pour un hôpital quelle
hiérarchie implicite cela révèle tout
cela me semble relever de l'absurdistant
avec le zan vous allez interdire le
développement des secteurs ruraux et
encourager la métropolisation notre pays
le zané bien à dispositif ruraliste vous
l'avez compris mon propos ne porte pas
sur le texte que nous étudions qui est
un texte
non pas dépourvu d'intérêt mais malgré
tout mineur mais bien sur le principe de
zéro artificialisation nette le texte
que nous examinons s'efforce de limiter
les dégâts mais je ne voudrais pas qu'il
cache l'essentiel en tout état de cause
nous ne cautionnons pas le zan pas plus
que l'ensemble des processus de
décroissance qui sont inhérents à cette
logique
parce que c'est bien le cas si le mode
décroissance n'apparaît pas dans le zan
il introduit cette notion il introduit
l'introduit cette notion de décroissance
sous une forme sous-jacente sous-jacente
et implicite et ceci est d'autant plus
hypocrite parce qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un
rejet du texte du Sénat mais bien d'un
rejet du zan lui-même et que je me
devais d'exprimer les convictions que le
règlement de l'Assemblée m'a permis
d'expliciter ici à cette tribune je
retire mon projet de rejet préalable
merci Monsieur Le Fur je prends donc
acte du retrait de votre émotion de
rejet préalable nous allons maintenant
entamer la discussion générale avec
Monsieur Sébastien Jumel pour le groupe
gauche-démocrate et républicaine up
c'est pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre ce rapporteur cher collègue je
vous remercier notre collègue Marc Le
Fur de nous avoir fait un beau cours de
dialectique marxiste
une opposition radicale et puis une
pirouette pour au bout du compte
renoncer à assumer
sa position mais je veux moins exposer
une position un peu plus pragmatique du
groupe communi sur ce sujet la
préservation du foncier est un enjeu de
la transition écologique c'est aussi un
enjeu majeur de la souveraineté
alimentaire cause massive de l'érosion
de la biodiversité l'artificialisation
des sols est un phénomène
qui serait irresponsable de ne pas
prendre en compte
personne ici ne peut en y est la
nécessité vitale or une stratégie n'est
valable moi je considère que l'écologie
ne peut pas être punitive une stratégie
n'est valable que si elle emporte avec
elle les acteurs ces gages d'efficacité
et de partage ce qui dès les premiers
jours du zan n'a pas été le cas bien au
contraire sa mise en place est apparue
très rapidement pour beaucoup comme une
usine à emmerdement comme le refus d'une
ruralité vivante déjà malmené par des
décennies d'abandon en tout genre
fermeture de service public baisse de
leur moyen les communes ont exprimé leur
refus de payer à elle seule les efforts
les effets de bord de décision bancale
venue d'en haut
en décidant de renvoyer des festivités
du zan à l'élaboration de degrés décret
publié dans la précipitation entre les
deux tours des présidentielles sont
concertation le pouvoir s'est offert une
occasion de plus de marquer sa distance
voir sa déconnexion avec la France d'en
bas c'est vrai pour le zan comme pour le
reste une décision n'est acceptée que
lorsque les parties prenantes sont
respectées pour les élus du groupe GDR
contrôler l'artificialisation des sols
et synonymes de recherche d'un équilibre
d'une ligne de crête difficile à obtenir
mais nécessaire à préserver cet
équilibre il tente d’être atteint
aujourd'hui avec la proposition de loi
en discussion
issue du travail transpartisan du Sénat
un texte qui considère des enjeux de
préservation du foncier avec la libre
administration des collectivités à
laquelle nous sommes évidemment
profondément attachés le droit au projet
n'est pas seulement une pétition de
principe mais doit pour les communes
être endroit réel nous considérons en
effet que les maires doivent demeurer
souverain dans leur commune sur la
question des aménagements les maires
nombreux dont mon territoire entre terre
et mer sont intelligents attachés à
préserver la beauté de leur paysage
toujours soucieux des équilibre de leur
territoire il ne supporte pas ni la
tutelle de l'État ni la tutelle des
régions et pour que nous avionschions
sur ce sujet au combien crucial pour
l'avenir il faut respecter la démocratie
c'est-à-dire ceux qui la font vivre
l'instant de démocratie vivante que
représente la commune cette question
principe est imposée la discussion a pu
être menée à bien la version du Sénat
nous semblait plus protectrice que le
texte adopté en commission qui fait la
part belle à des renvois au domaine
réglementaires pour près de la moitié
des articles initiaux
je le mini je vous l'ai dit en
tête-à-tête faudra pas trop vous
habituer à cette manière de légiférer
même si nous avons perçu la nécessité
pour être rapide efficace de procéder de
la sorte ce texte si ce texte avance par
exemple en garantie son commune un droit
d'aménagement avec la garantie rurale ou
en prenant en compte le retrait du trait
de côte c'est en Normandie un sujet
important il demeure des points
d'amélioration pour les grands projets
par exemple nous considérons que nous
devons encore donner des garanties plus
fortes au territoire qui vont en
accueillir je me réjouis que mon
amendement sur le père pour faire
reconnaître le BR comme projet d'intérêt
national et européen ait été retenus en
commission mais je compte sur mes
collègues attachés à la relance de cette
filière pour aller plus loin en
intégrant par exemple chez le ministre
les hectares de parking nécessaires pour
un chantier comme le père à panier 12
hectares c'est réversible des parkings
pour intégrer des externes nécessaires
aux hébergements tempor Aires ces
réversible les hectares nécessaires aux
hébergements temporaires pour intégrer
les dizaines d'hectares nécessaires pour
les postes des lignes à haute tension
pour le parc éolien offshore du Tréport
dont je me suis
transformé en opposant fort il faut donc
il faut donc avancer sur cette question
des grands projets si nous voulons
qu'ils soient exemplaire au plan social
et au plan environnemental c'est
notamment je veux aller vite mais je
veux porter la parole de mes collègues
ultramarins il faudra prendre en compte
dans les discussions la question de la
spécificité des Outre-mer sinon et ils
ne pourront pas envisager un
développement harmonieux cohérent de
leur territoire on compte sur vous
évidemment là-dessus il faudra aussi
Monsieur le Ministre concrètement
accompagner les maires sur les fronts
friches sur l'ingénierie dont on besoin
les petites communes pour s'occuper des
friction industrielles voilà l'état
d'esprit constructif dans lequel le
groupe GDR se trouve pour apprendre ce
texte merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Monsieur Luc l'amirault
pour le groupe horizon et la parenté
pour 5 minutes
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues
les dix dernières années
ont été marqués par une diminution
progressive des surfaces artificialisées
passons de 40000 hectares par an dans
les années 2000 à 20000 en 2021
la consommation de terres agricoles et
naturelle à un impact désomets reconnus
sur notre réchauffement climatique il
nous faut donc être volontariste pour
diminuer les risques qui pèsent sur
notre environnement notre biodiversité
et pour diminuer et ce et se lier au
risque de ruissellement pardon comme en
témoigne les images des inondations dans
de nombreux territoires
cependant nous ne pouvons pas changer de
modèle de vie aussi rapidement nous
avons donc fait le choix au sein de la
loi climat et résilience de réduire de
50% de notre consommation d'ici 2031 et
une absence de consommation totale de
notaire à compter de 2050
une accélération aussi violente nos
pratiques a suscité inquiétude et
incompréhension
ce texte examinait aujourd'hui et le
fruit d'un terrain est réalisé entre les
sénateurs nos deux rapporteurs Lionel
Causse et Bastien narchives et le
ministre Christophe Béchu afin de
surmonter les difficultés de mise en
œuvre rencontrées par les élus locaux
l'article premier de cette proposition
de loi améliorera le dialogue et
permettra de trouver localement les
objectifs partagés les conférences
régionales d'usane ouvrira ses portes à
plus de représentativité et donnera
davantage la parole aux élus locaux dans
le cadre de cette conférence les régions
devront faire preuve de conviction et de
pédagogie pour expliquer leur position
parfois plus strictes que la loi à titre
d'exemple la région Centre-Val de Loire
a fait le choix dans son schéma régional
d'une réduction de 50% d'ici 2025 et un
objectif de 0 artificialisation nette
d'ici 2040
comme le défend l'association des mers
ruraux de France ce sont les projets qui
définissent l'espace à mobiliser et non
l'inverse c'est avec cette logique que
le dialogue avec les régions doit être
mise en place la garantie rurale et la
mutualisation des projets permettront à
chaque commune et à leurs conseils
municipaux d'agir concrètement sur leur
développement tout en discussant aux
discutant au sein de leur
intercommunalité de la possibilité de
mutualiser les droits à construire afin
de permettre la réalisation de projets
de plus grandes ampleur
les territoires ruraux littoraux
impactés par la montée des eaux et le
recul du trait de côte verront leurs
zones inutilisable considérées comme
renaturées afin de comptabiliser les
efforts déjà réalisés par les communes
sur la renaturation nous avons seront
nous avons ce qu'on leur prise en compte
de 2031 à 2021
toujours dans l'objectif d'apporter une
meilleure articulation avec les régions
la définition des projets d'ampleur
national et européenne a été clarifiée
comme c'est et ceux issus de l'industrie
verte leur emprise ne permettra de
remettre pas en cause les objectifs
fixés par la loi
la réduction de consommation foncière
nous oblige à porter une attention
particulière au programme de
restauration du bâti
au cœur de nos villages et de nos
centres bourg la restauration sera un
enjeu majeur pour accompagner nos
besoins de logement
concernant le développement économique
les efforts financiers de l'État dans le
cadre du fond vert et du fond friche ont
été réalisés devront être poursuivis et
devons également concerner les projets
de renaturation
comme évoqué au début de mes propos ce
texte sera complété par plusieurs
projets de décret dont les principaux
nous ont déjà été présentés le 13 juin
dernier l'important sur la nomenclature
d'usage et l'autre sur la mise en
œuvre via les
vous l'avez bien compris
au groupe horizon à parenté nous
considérons que ce texte améliorera le
dialogue et répond aux questions de
nombreux élus tout en maintenant notre
volonté de répondre aux défis climatique
mais avec progressivité donc le groupe
horizon et parenté votre rapport ce
texte merci
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Madame Lisa belluko pour le groupe
écologiste
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur les rapporteurs chers
collègues
nous avons toujours sous les pieds la
même planète mais plus tout à fait la
même terre car depuis deux siècles cette
terre nous ne l'avons regardé que comme
un simple une simple surface les terres
étaient à découvrir à conquérir à
cultiver à bâtir le monde n'avait que
deux dimensions la longueur et la
largeur ceux de la parcelle cadastrale
à quoi nous a conduit cette vision plate
à la mise à mort de nos sols dont nous
avons oublié qu'ils étaient vivants
alors même que la population croit à
peine nous artificialisations encore
aujourd'hui à raison de 25000 hectares
par an
l'équivalent de deux fois et demi la
surface de Paris est ensevelie chaque
année sous le béton dans notre pays mais
à 21e siècle il nous faut atterrir comme
dirait Bruno Latour quitter cette vision
littéralement hors sol pour considérer
les sols non plus comme de simples
supports mais comme des écosystèmes qui
assurent les fonctions indispensables au
bon fonctionnement de notre société et
du vivant car c'est seuls vivants
retiennent l'eau lui permettent de
s'infiltrer et de recharger les nappes
il réduisent les risques d'inondation et
assure notre résilience face aux
sécheresses ils abritent des millions de
micro-organismes sources fertilité de
régulation des ravageurs il limite le
lessivage des sols et retiennent jusqu'à
80 tonnes de carbone par hectare leur
existence et leur préservation sont les
conditions de possibilité de notre
souveraineté alimentaire puisqu'ils
constituent l'outil de travail des
paysans et paysannes qui nous
nourrissent au quotidien
il y a eu peu d'avancées dans la loi
climat et résilience votée à l'issue de
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
mais cette assemblée a voté ici pour
organiser la fin de l'artificialisation
des sols en réduisant par deux cet
artificialisation d'ici 2031 et en la
conditionnant une renaturation d'ici
aucun ni aucune élue ne peut prétendre
défendre ni l'environnement ni nos
agriculteurs si cet élu vote ici pour
revenir sur ses acquis c'est pourtant la
ligne commune de la droite et de
l'extrême droite qui dépose des
amendements identiques pour supprimer
tous les objectifs et tous les leviers
pour garder nos sols vivants et
préserver notre souveraineté alimentaire
c'est la ligne de ceux qui vote pour que
des autoroutes traversent nos terroirs
qu'ils affirment pourtant chérir c'est
la ligne de ceux qui clament un droit du
sol sans jamais OpenSER aux droits des
sols qui nous nourrissent quand on aime
son pays on ne lance pas sous le béton
à l'inverse monsieur le ministre et bien
que vous souteniez main dans la main
avec les bétonnaires destructeurs la
dissolution de groupes écologistes qui
luttent contre cette bétonisation
je salue tout de même votre engagement
de tenir ses objectifs
malgré les assauts de votre collègue
Bruno Le Maire pour ne pas comptabiliser
l'artificialisation du projet industriel
le travail que nous avons mené en
commission a déjà permis de supprimer du
texte les dispositions les plus
inquiétantes néanmoins il reste beaucoup
à faire pour protéger nos sols
il y a d'abord le blanc ça pour les
grands projets inutiles et imposés les
Pharaons ont érigé les pyramides Louis
XIV a fait construire son facieux
château de Versailles vos grands projets
aujourd'hui se sont les autoroutes les
centrales nucléaires la LGV les
gigafactory quel que soit le système
politique le pouvoir manifeste assure sa
domination par la grande îlotense
d'infrastructure supposée recueillir
l'accueil enthousiaste de citoyens
flattés
pour se convaincre chers
convaincre de leur caractère délétère du
point de vue de la destruction des sols
je rappelle juste quelques chiffres
1500 pour le lion Turin 400 pour
l'autoroute Castres Toulouse 6300 pour
la ligne Bordeaux Toulouse c'est la
surface en hectare de sol
irréversiblement artificialisé par ces
infrastructures d'un autre temps
15000 hectares seront détruits par ces
projets c'est une estimation car il est
déjà prévu que ce plafond puisse être
dépassé dans le texte
s'il doit y avoir une artificialisation
réduite dans les années à venir elle
doit être planifiée à l'échelle locale
pour bénéficier à des projets locaux
construction de pistes cyclables pour
relier les Bours réouverture de lignes
ferroviaire du quotidien développement
d'unités de production artisanale
infrastructures accueillant des services
publics ce sont des éléments qui
assureront un développement rural plutôt
que la mesure simpliste pour ne pas dire
démagogique qui consiste à garantir une
artificialisation rurale pour tous et
sans condition toutes les communes n'ont
pas les mêmes projets qu'elles aient 40
habitants ou 10000 l'approche doit être
équitable plutôt qu'egalitariste
nous n'avons aucune étude d'impact sur
les effets Corinne telle mesure ni sur
l'état des sols ni sur la planification
à l'échelle intercommunale il faut au
moins s’assurer que seuls les communes
ayant fait preuve d'une sobriété
foncière pourront au bénéficier et que
cette garantie sera plafonnée
si ces mesures contre-productives ne
sont pas supprimées ou si d'autres
venaient à être adoptés nous ne pourrons
pas nous prononcer en faveur de ce texte
à l'inverse si nous ne si nous le
saisissons collectivement comme une
opportunité de faire planifier la
transition écologique à l'échelle des
territoires et rehausser les mesures de
protection de nos sols nous pourrons le
soutenir
merci madame la députée la parole est à
Monsieur Stéphane delautraite pour le
groupe socialiste et à parenté et pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues la transition écologique
est une urgence qui repose sur plusieurs
piliers dans les effets se croisent
transition énergétique par la
décarbonation et la sobriété transition
accro agroécologie ou encore
préservation de la biodiversité et de la
ressource en nous le constat est que
nous artificialisons l'équivalent de
quatre terrains de football par heure
soit l'équivalent en 20 temps de la
surface totale de mon département de la
Haute-Vienne ce rythme est en outre
trois fois et demi plus dynamique que
celui de la démographie or
l'artificialisation des sols porte
considérablement atteinte à la
biodiversité contribue au réchauffement
climatique en réduisant la capacité de
stockage de carbone du sol et perturbe
le bon écoulement des eaux en augmentant
ainsi le risque naturel
convaincu que ce rythme n'était plus
tenable notre groupe a soutenu et voté
dans la loi dite climat et résilience en
2021 un objectif national visant à
atteindre un rythme d'artificiel
d'artificialisation nette nulle d'ici
2050 avec une première réduction de
moitié de celui-ci entre 2021 et 2031 ce
sont les conditions de la mise en oeuvre
de cette première phase qui nous
réunissent aujourd'hui malheureusement
nous sommes collectivement à côté du
sujet en effet cette proposition de loi
qui se voulait corriger des
insuffisances d'usage ne répond pas aux
besoins de mesure de programmation sur
la maîtrise foncière et l'usage des sols
alors que nous prévoyons leur arrêt
faction en nous donnant l'objectif de
diviser par deux la consommation
d'espèces naturelles agricoles et
forestiers sur la décennie à venir nous
engageons une course offensiers qui
appelle à une double régulation une
régulation d'usage tout d'abord en
veillant à ce que les autres objectifs
de politique le public qui sont les
nôtres comme la production de logements
ou la réindustrialisation par exemple
n'entre pas en conflit ensuite une
régulation économique en nous donnant
les outils d'une maîtrise de la valeur
du foncier afin de limiter la
spéculation et la rétention foncière qui
ne ferait que rendre plus complexe
l'équilibre économique de certains
projets au détriment de l'intérêt
général cela vaut également pour les
surfaces déjà artificialisées qu'il
faudra densifier recycler réhabiliter et
parfois renaturé pour atteindre les
objectifs il est donc urgent monsieur le
ministre que nous puissions disposer
d'une grande loi de programmation
foncière maintes fois annoncée mais
désormais essentiel
la prochaine loi de finances devra par
ailleurs mettre en oeuvre des crédits et
des mesures fiscales volontariste pour
accompagner nos collectivités et en
particulier les plus petites d'entre
elles dans la réhabilitation d'immeubles
la transformation de friches et la
préservation des sols et 9
constructibles sont ces outils nos
objectifs resteront des vœux pieux pour
en venir au fond de ce texte n'ayant ni
les moyens de réhabiliter ou de
transformer leur espace déjà urbanisé ni
parfois de réaliser des documents
d'urbanisme les petites communes rurales
lancent une forme d'appel à l'aide en
demandant à conserver une perspective de
développement c'est ainsi qu'il faut
comprendre la demande de garantie rurale
dans l'attente d'autres outils pour se
développer à l'intérieur des zones
urbanisées nous proposerons donc de
continuer à donner de la flexibilité et
de l'agilité à cette garantie rurale de
favoriser la mutualisation
intercommunale et de ne pas pénaliser
les communes relevant du RNU pour autant
revenir sur le principe de
constructibilité limitée autrement dit
une garantie rurale souple et
intelligente est possible nous
proposerons également de préciser le
périmètre des projets relevant de la
définition de projet d'intérêt national
ou européen c'est une condition du
respect de l'enveloppe du forfait
national et donc de celle disponible
pour les projets régionaux et locaux
nous veillerons également à bien
préciser l'articulation de ces
enveloppes afin que leur agrégation se
traduisent effectivement par le respect
de l'objectif de réduction de moitié du
rythme d'artificialisation enfin nous
veillerons à préciser des mesures
applicables dans la bande littorale tant
pour éviter les abus que pour assurer
une meilleure intégration des
spécificités de nos territoires
ultramarins monsieur le ministre
messieurs les rapporteurs ce texte a
connu une évolution favorable en
commission sur les délais la définition
des projets leur comptabilité
nous pouvons encore améliorer ce texte
et donner des raisons au sénateur de se
rallier à sa rédaction alors saisissez
notre main tendue merci merci monsieur
le député
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Paul Molac pour
le groupe liberté indépendant outre-mer
et territoire et pour 5 minutes
madame la rapporteur messieurs les
rapporteurs commission mes chers
collègues
nous considérons au sein de notre groupe
que ce texte est nécessaire et bienvenue
evidemment
l'artificialisation continue de notaire
la réduction de la consommation des
espaces naturels agricoles et forestiers
et une nécessité toutefois nous ne
parviendrons à lutter contre
l'artificialisation des sols qu'à
condition d'assurer la faisabilité et
l'acceptabilité de l'objectif 0
artificialisation nette
celui-ci doit pouvoir être concilié avec
les enjeux locaux notamment économiques
mais aussi avec une politique d'habitat
et d'accueil des populations nouvelles
nous avons tous été destinataires des
remontées de terrain d'élus locaux et
d'acteurs de territoire ils nous ont
fait part de leurs inquiétudes face aux
risques de ne plus pouvoir construire ou
aménager leur territoire sont aussi
remontés à nos oreilles des difficultés
résultantes d'un manque de visibilité
sur les règles applicables que ce soit
sur la nomenclature des seuls
artificialisés
actuellement en réécriture ou le manque
de données sur l'artificialisation
passée les sénateurs ont saisi la
nécessité d'apporter davantage de
flexibilité à un principe aujourd'hui
inadapté aux réalités territoriales ils
ont eu bien raison
le développement et la vitalité des
zones rurales est au cœur de nos
préoccupations c'est en ce sens que
notre groupe accueille favorablement la
garantie rurale visant à permettre au
plus petites communes de pouvoir dégager
des marches des marges de manœuvre afin
de pouvoir générer les infrastructures
de services développer leur capacité
d'habitat notamment dans les zones
tendues ou encore procéder à des
constructions nécessaires par exemple à
l'activité agricole
Lausanne ne doit pas se traduire par une
application purement mathématique et
rigide mais au contraire permettent la
prise en compte de la diversité de nos
territoires et de leur structuration
par exemple
dans la Bretagne administrative celle
qui compte 4 départements contrairement
à la Bretagne qui ont compte 5 la
population augmente de plus de 20 000
habitants chaque année
la pression foncière due à cette
dynamique démographique provoque de
fortes tensions économiques et sociales
qui ne saurait être négligée c'est
pourquoi mon groupe proposera de prendre
en compte ces évolutions démographiques
dans la territorialisation du Zéro
artificialisation nette je souhaite par
ailleurs attirer l'attention de
gouvernement sur un point fondamental
qui pourrait constituer un effet de bord
vous le savez la dotation globale de
fonctionnement versé au collectivités et
corrélés de manière directe par rapport
à la croissance et au développement de
la collectivité plus
d'infrastructures plus de logements plus
d'artificialisation égale plus de DGF
cela pose quand même un problème donc il
sera nécessaire à un moment donné de
revoir évidemment le
la façon dont nous donnons finalement
des dotations à ces communes qui
préservent la terre agricole et les
espaces naturels
autre sujet source de préoccupation dans
nos territoires celui de la prise en
compte des projets d'envergure national
vous proposez aux enduit la mise en
place d'un forfait national de 15000
hectares qui sera décompté dès 125 000
hectares qui représentent l'enveloppe
nationale le reste de l'enveloppe 110
000 hectares donc devra être répartis
entre les régions selon un système de
pondération nous avons toujours des
doutes quant aux caractères opérant de
cette proposition les régions qui
accueillent peu de projets d'ampleur
accepteront-elles de porter le poids du
collectif alors qu'elle n'en perçoivent
pas les retombées
pas enfin que nous sommes ici en train
de légiférer mais que nos élus locaux
seront en première ligne face à nos
concitoyens afin d'entendre leur
doléances en matière d'urbanisation
l'État doit être au rendez-vous et doit
accompagner les élus locaux afin que cet
objectif louable de préservation des
terres agricoles ne finissent pas par
des manifestations massives face à des
situations de crise je dis cela à
descend je vis dans un territoire qui
subit actuellement une crise majeure du
logement avec une colère qui monte et se
fait sentir pour toutes ces raisons nous
serons favorables aux mesures
d'adaptation des objectifs du Zéro
artificialisation nette aux réalités
territoriales et les assouplissements
bienvenue au service des élus locaux et
de finalement
puisqu'il me reste quelques quelques
secondes
on a souvent parlé de l'Allemagne on a
souvent parlé du Royaume-Uni mais ce
sont des pays qui sont beaucoup plus
industrialisés et qui sont beaucoup plus
urbanisés que nous or l'Insee a choisi
2000 habitants agglomérés pour définir
ce qu'est un milieu urbain
l'Italie a choisi 5000 habitants
agglomérés on voit bien que quelque part
on surjoue et que la France reste un
pays rural et c'est important parce que
ça fait partie aussi de ce que nous
sommes et qu'il ne faudrait pas
l'oublier je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Pascal Lavergne pour le groupe
Renaissance et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci Madame madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre monsieur les
rapporteurs madame la Présidente de
commission les enjeux environnementaux
de la protection de la biodiversité ont
été pleinement pris à bras le corps par
notre groupe et notre majorité
présidentielle ces enjeux par leur
transversalité touche tous les secteurs
des politiques publiques le débat qui
s'ouvre aujourd'hui est un débat qui me
parle tout particulièrement en tant qu'
ancien maire d'une commune rurale mais
aussi vice-président de communauté de
communes en charge de l'urbanisme j'ai
pu mesurer toute la patient qui entoure
les sujets de construction d'un projet
d'urbanisme commun c'est évidemment
l'avenir des territoires qui se jouent
mais j'ai pu également constater à quel
point on se rangeait trop facilement à
admettre que développer un territoire
c'était l'équivalent du fait de
grignoter des terres agricoles souvent
les plus fertiles sur le plan
agronomique
on profite d'un désir de maisons
individuelle et d'un jardin de 2500
mètres carrés en fermant souvent les
populations dans des contraintes
pendulaires non anticipées entre 2011 et
2021 ça a été dit à plusieurs reprises
c'est plus de 250 000 hectares qui ont
été consommés soit l'équivalent du
département des Yvelines le foncier
renvoie à des enjeux multiples qui sont
finalement au cœur des politiques
d'aménagement du territoire c'est-à-dire
la répartition équilibrée entre les
hommes et les activités je pense ici
effectivement aux enjeux agricoles et à
la souveraineté alimentaire mais aussi à
la production énergétique verte ou
encore au développement
d'infrastructures de transport de
service ou industriels notre pays est
riche de ces territoires où les modes
d'urbanisation rivalisent d'ingéniosité
je pense ici au bastide il en existe 64
en Aquitaine 8 dans le département de la
Gironde et j'ai eu la chance d'être
maire de la plus belle d'entre elles
cette urbanisme
vieux de 750 ans je pense à celui
évidemment des bastides dévoilent toute
sa pertinence aujourd'hui peu gourmand
en consommation foncière le bâti
s'organise autour d'une place centrale
d'un plan à quadrillage sur des lots
largeur pour 3 profondeurs le pourtour
de la place et le lieu où s'établissent
les commerces et les services le cœur de
la place et le lieu du marché des foires
là où la vie culturelle s'épanouit c'est
cette place c'est aussi l'Agora c'est là
où on s'engueule le lundi avec son
beau-frère insoumis mais c'est aussi là
où le mercredi soir au marché nocturne
on partage une entrecôte et on serait
concilie ce propos nous encourage à être
aussi inventif et audacieux dans nos
projets urbains en les rendant plus
humain en les ouvrant sur le vivre
ensemble et en étant moins dispendieux
de notre terre
en ce sens la loi kribbale résilience du
22 août 2021 a formulé un objectif celui
de réduire de moitié l'artificialisation
nouvelle entre 2021 et 2031 par rapport
à la décennie précédente et d'atteindre
d'ici 2050 une artificialisation nette
de 0% le zanne c'est-à-dire au moins
autant en refusant de surface renaturée
que de surface artificialisée lisons le
nous tout ceci va dans le bon sens les
objectifs de ce texte sont clairs
favoriser le dialogue territorial et
renforcé la gouvernance des centralisée
en permettant le dialogue des
collectivités au sein d'une conférence
régionale on encourage les coopérations
fertiles et les regards croisés et on
renforce l'action locale à laquelle je
suis pleinement attaché
accompagné les projets structurants de
demain la
comptabilisation des projets nationaux
et régionaux permet à chacun de prendre
ses responsabilités et d'être
en phase avec son besoin de
développement sans obérer celui du
territoire supra ou infra mieux prendre
en compte les spécificités des
territoires la garantie rurale donnera
un minimum de superficie
urbanisable pour respecter chaque
commune même si je pense dans mon foire
intérieur que ce minimum de dépend pas
d'un nombre d'habitants mais d'autres
critères comme nous avons pu les définir
dans le cadre du plui dont j'avais la
charge telle que la disponibilité en eau
et la présence des services publics sur
structurants mais là aussi faisant
confiance au territoire pour coopérer
pour trouver les bonnes solutions à
partir des projets construits
collectivement prévoir les outils de
transition vers Lausanne le texte
issu des travaux parlementaires du Sénat
et des commissions économiques et
développement durables de l'Assemblée
nationale sont permettre d'avoir un
meilleur équilibre entre les projets et
nationaux régionaux et locaux comme je
viens de l'indiquer sur ces sujets la
tentation électoraliste est forte pour
autant c'est l'intérêt national de ce
dispositif qui doit être apprécié face
au défi qui nous guettent nous avons le
devoir de produire un texte le plus
consensuel possible qui tient compte de
tous les enjeux en répondant aux
inquiétudes du monde rural qui dans la
version précédente du texte en vigueur
s'estimé des possédés de toutes
capacités de manœuvre pour se développer
le fait régional le fait territorial le
fait communautaire existe bel et bien et
chacun doit prendre ses responsabilités
merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Madame Christine en
grand pour le groupe rassemblement
national et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur les rapporteurs et
chers collègues le législateur devrait
cesser d'ériger en dogme en recette
miracle en vérité absolue des notions
telles que le renouvellement urbain ou
la densification qui peuvent s'affairer
pertinentes ici ou là selon la qualité
des projets urbains qui les concrétise
mais ne peuvent prétendre de constituer
la seule pierre de touche de la
politique urbaine ces mots justes écrits
en 2012 ne sont pas ceux du
rassemblement national mais d'un article
intitulé la densification une vérité
devenue folle de Sylvain Pérignon ancien
directeur de recherche au CRIDON de
Paris 9 ans plus tard en 2021 vous
adoptiez ici même la loi climat climat
et résilience un texte bardé de
contraintes normative relevant davantage
de la pensée magique que d'une réflexion
politique équilibrée sur la
densification nos députés n'étaient
alors pas suffisamment nombreux pour
s'opposer à l'application de ses
objectifs inadaptés à nos territoires
auxquels chers collègues galère vous ne
trouviez alors rien à redire il faut
dire que les élections sénatoriales
avaient déjà eu lieu pourtant déjà cette
même place notre présidente de groupe
prédisait l'échec de l'écologie punitive
dont le fameux zéro artificialisation
nette plus communément appelé le SAN
détient certainement la palme d'or de
ces objectifs les plus drastiques
d'Europe la plupart des mers ne
retiennent d'ailleurs que l'iniquité qui
en découle les communes qui ont le plus
artificialisé ces dernières années
peuvent toujours le faire tandis que les
communes rurales ou peuplées qui
n’artificialisent que très peu sont
d'ores et déjà condamnés dans votre
frénésie normative vous ne voyez pas de
problème à contraindre indistinctement
nos communes de quelques centaines
d'habitants de la même manière que nous
sommes immenses métropoles avec toutes
les conséquences que l'on connaît pour
l'installation de service essentiels
qu'il s'agisse d'infrastructures
sportives de centre de soins ou même de
services publics donc dans pletteur de
commune qui n'ont pas attendu le
législateur pour faire preuve de
sobriété foncière en outre on retrouve
dans les zones de revitalisation rurale
une véritable éthique
entre artificialisé partout ou
artificialisé nulle part quand certains
appelaient à construire des Versailles
pour le peuple aujourd'hui vous proposez
des grignies dans la Creuse la
caricature est à peine exagérer avec un
déficit annoncé de 850 000 logements en
2030 devine d'évidence le renouvellement
urbain
qu'il passe par la réhabilitation des
fiches ou la renaturation ne suffira pas
absorber la demande pour respecter le
zan et loger les citoyens que la hausse
du prix des fonciers privera de l'accès
à la propriété même en réalité il faudra
plus d'immeubles collectifs et
redécouper les bâtisses existantes pour
loger plus de monde dans moins d'espace
les écolos en a rêvé vous l'exaucez le
logement individuel avec jardin le rêve
pour de nombreux français devient
maintenant un vrai luxe de cet échec
collectif vous êtes tous comptables
autant que vous êtes nous sommes ici les
seuls présents qui n'avions pas eu notre
mot à dire alors cette fois-ci disons-le
franchement le zan ne saurait être
l'alpha et l'oméga de l'aménagement du
territoire une politique de réduction de
l'artificialisation des sols réussis
par une déclinaison à une déclinaison
adaptée de ses objectifs aux
spécificités territoriales conciliant à
la fois la densification et le
développement local nécessaire à la
démétropolisation à ce titre le zinc
doit être recalibré pour peser
principalement sur les mauvais élèves et
récompenser ou du moins ne pas
handicaper les très nombreuses communes
qui ont toujours respecté la terre et
ceux qui ont vivent la mise en place
d'une politique de réduction de
l'artificialisation des sols cohérente
territorialement et raisonnable
juridiquement est possible c'est ce que
nous défendrons quand votre de contre
votre demi mesure mais elle ne pourra
faire l'économie d'une réappropriation
de ses objectifs par les élus municipaux
desquels chers collègues vous devez
cesser de vous défier la régionalisation
ne serait-ce substituer au bon sens de
nos élus municipaux il enleva de
l'avenir de nos communes de l'avenir de
nos communes et des aspirations des
Français en fonction de l'avance des
débats nous positionnerons sur le texte
merci
madame la députée
la parole est à Madame Catherine
couturier pour la France insoumise du
fait c'est pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs
collègues quatre terrains de foot
artificiels c'est par heure voilà
l'image à retenir de notre territoire
avec l'explosion de la bétonisation et
du tout-voiture si ce texte garde
l'objectif de réduire de 50 % brut de
l'artificialisation à l'horizon 2031
l'environ 125 000 hectares et 0,9 en
2050 avec 170 000 hectares de friches
nous avons largement la capacité de
viser une neutralité foncière dès 2040
objectifs que nous porterons dans un
amendement
alors que de très nombreuses communes
ont joué le jeu de la sobriété foncière
alors que les communes rurales les plus
vertueuses vivent Lausanne comme une
injustice le gouvernement lui s'autorise
à l'article 4 une liste interminable des
projets d'ampleur national ou européenne
elle inclut tout projet d'utilité
publique fixé par décret et non par la
loi
le pire cette liste comporte des projets
écossides qui ne contribuent pas à
l'intérêt général quand monsieur le
ministre nous affirme en commission que
les autoroutes du Bas-Chablais pour 16
km le lion Turin la 69 Toulouse Castres
où les projets nucléaires font partie de
ces projets d'envergure nationale où est
donc l'intérêt général la sobriété
environnementale ne peut pas être à
géométrie variable j'attire votre
attention sur le fait que le Sénat a
voté le 15 juin pour exclure les projets
d'industrie soi-disant verte de
l'enveloppe d'artificialisation comme le
souhaitait Monsieur le Maire encore une
fois la droite sauve la macronie par des
petits arrangements en sous-main
monsieur le ministre Béchu messieurs les
rapporteurs vous avez affirmé vouloir
inclure les grands projets d'État dans
l'enveloppe globale à ne pas dépasser et
vous avez eu raison
allez vous plier devant Bercy allez vous
céder au sénateur en quête de réélection
ou rendez-vous vos responsabilités
devant le scénario a+4 degrés le groupe
et les filles du peste restera vigilant
sur la garantie rurale à l'article 7 la
version de votre texte est encore trop
incertaine et ne répond pas aux attentes
de la ruralité ni à la préservation des
terres agricoles et des forêts en
fonction de la taille des communes un
hectare cela peut être très peu ou trop
c'est pourquoi nous préférons le
principe en pourcentage et nous
proposons de conditionner la garantie
rurale sur la base d'indicateurs tels
que le taux de logement vacants le
respect environnemental ou les normes
srue ce n'est pas la garantie rurale qui
redémarisera nos campagnes mais bien une
volonté politique d'aménagement du
territoire par plus de services publics
des transports du quotidien des écoles
des petits commerces en centre bourg des
médecins et de l'emploi local
au-delà du contenu de ce texte parlons
de ce qu'il n'y ait pas sur les
outre-mer monsieur le ministre vous
aviez clairement affirmé en commission
qu'il fallait des dispositions
spécifiques à ces territoires ils n'y
sont pas vous avez encore la possibilité
d'y remédier comme le préconise
l'association des mers ruraux la France
a besoin d'un véritable plan Marshall
pour le bâti vacances la vacances de
logement est aujourd'hui de 1 sur 10 un
droit de préemption et faciliter
l'acquisition des biens vacances en
mètres pour les communes sont
indispensables ce texte ne revient pas
sur le cas des friches industrielles 170
000 hectares il se contente de répartir
le gâteau et de donner des directives
aux collectivités sans leur en donner
les moyens aucun levier de procédure
aucune simplification administrative
aucun moyen supplémentaire à louer votre
gouvernement se défausse encore sur les
collectivités et cela alors même que nos
communes souffrent déjà de la
suppression des impôts locaux et de la
CVAE d'une DGF en dessous de l'inflation
ne me dites pas que c'est faux toutes
les associations d'élus ont boycoté vos
assises des finances publiques
finalement rien sur les leviers fiscaux
aujourd'hui la fiscalité locale
encourage encore les communes à bâtir
toujours plus car leur recette dépendent
notamment de la taxe d'aménagement et de
la taxe foncière d'autant plus que le
zan risque de créer une augmentation des
prix du foncier et davantage de
spéculation les grues les groupes de la
nupesse sont donc proposés des
amendements visant à combattre ce fléau
encore une fois l'Assemblée nationale
Chambre du peuple et expression de la
volonté populaire n'a pas pu s'exprimer
au regard de désormais fameux article 40
monsieur le ministre vous nous avez
envoyé en commission PLF pour parler de
la transition fiscale nous vous y
attendrons avec de nombreuses
propositions si vous choisissez le débat
et pas le 49.3 collègues ce texte est
donc loin d'être à la hauteur des
ambitions que nous devons nous fixer
nous avons proposé des amendements pour
plus d'équités territoriales et
d'ambitions environnementales leur
adoption ou pas définiront notre
position finale sur ce texte merci
madame la députée
la parole est à Madame
haut de Lucky pour les démocrates mais
c'est pas
ah pardon excusez-moi monsieur Rolland
pour les républicains et pour 5 minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires économiques
messieurs les rapporteurs
l'Assemblée nationale examine
aujourd'hui une proposition de loi
particulièrement importante pour nos
concitoyens un texte d'apparence
technique mais qui en réalité concerne
tous les français
puisqu'il traitent à la fois de
l'aménagement du territoire des
répercussions sur la construction de
nouveaux logements et sur le
développement économique dans son
ensemble la question du foncier est à ce
titre un sujet brûlant oui
l'utilisation plus vertueuse de nos
terres est une ambition partagée par
tous mais encore faut-il que cette
ambition soit réaliste et qu'elle ne
vienne pas tuer toute initiative de
développement dans nos communes
or c'est ce à quoi nous assistons mes
chers collègues la réalité c'est que
depuis des décennies la France s'est
désindustrialisée que nous avons besoin
de faire revenir les emplois sur notre
territoire ce qui implique évidemment de
trouver du foncier je profite de cette
tribune pour rappeler à toute personne
soucieuse de la préservation de
l'environnement qu'au de la même de
l'intérêt économique que cela engendre
pour nos emplois nous devrions tous nous
réjouir de retrouver des productions
plus locales plutôt que de fermer les
yeux sur le bilan carbone de nos
importations
telle que votée en 2019 dans la loi
climat est résilience
issus de la convention citoyenne
porterait un rude coup à toutes les
initiatives soutenues par nos élus
locaux
proposé par nos collègues sénateurs le
texte qui est désormais devant nous a
fait l'objet de plusieurs modifications
en commission avec un principe simple
celui du travail en confiance fruit d'un
travail mené de manière transpartisane
des sénateurs LR au sénateur communiste
et en réponse aux injonctions
irréalisables votées sous le mandat
précédent qui nous conduisait à une
logique de décroissance notre groupe
entend agir pour chercher des
améliorations à défaut de pouvoir
revenir sur la philosophie générale
l'attente est forte il faut dire que
dans les territoires de montagne comme
partout dans les territoires ruraux
l'inquiétude pèse de plus en plus sur
l'application de cette mesure les
risques sont multiples
stopper net tout développement
économique de nos territoires au profit
des polluants et surtout mettre à mal la
construction d'habitat permanent au
moment où les Français n'arrivent déjà
plus à se loger car ces mécaniques en
raréfiant le Frontier avec une ambition
0 artificialisation nette d'ici 2050 par
tranche de moins de 50% tous les 10 ans
les prix vont continuer d'augmenter
indéniablement pour les Français la
question est désormais de répartir
l'effort territorialement sans que nos
petites communes soient pénalisées
tout l'enjeu sera donc de préserver
l'équilibre entre le développement rural
et urbain des communes du littoral en
passant par celles plus rurales sans
oublier évidemment nos territoires de
montagne auxquels vous connaissez mon
attachement c'est déclinaisons
territoriales doivent prendre en compte
nos spécificités afin de préserver leur
attrait touristique et économique
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous préférerons toujours les avancées
même à minima qu'au statu quo nous
aurons à cœur de faire valoir nos
arguments lors de nos débats qui
arrivent et c'est
arguments j'espère permettront de
l'adhésion du gouvernement est peut-être
de notre vote je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député et cette fois la
parole est à Madame haut de Luquet pour
le groupe démocrate et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la prise madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteurs mes chers collègues à la fin
de notre discussion générale nous aurons
en France artificialiser l'équivalent de
8 terrains de football Didier
artificialisation dit des terres
naturels que l'on grignote avec les
conséquences que l'on connaît des
conséquences non seulement sur le vivant
et notre biodiversité mais aussi pour
nos concitoyens que l'on éloigne
toujours un peu plus des centres et des
services qui les accompagnent divisé par
deux artificialisation des sols d'ici
2031 pour aller vers le 0
artificialisation nette en 2050 c'est
donc une mesure à la fois
environnementale sociale et économique
environnemental d'abord elle nous permet
de lutter contre la fragmentation des
espaces naturels et de replacer la
nature et ses vertus pour le commun au
cœur de nos projets d'aménagement dans
des territoires carenciers en espace
vert ou la biodiversité étant déclin
refaire la ville sur elle-même doit
permettre de développer de nouvelles
formes d'intégration de la nature c'est
un enjeu fondamental pour faire face la
conséquence du changement climatique et
renforcer le bien-être de ceux qui
vivent où ils travaillent en ne
considant plus le sol comme une simple
surface mais en prenant en compte
pleinement ses fonctions écologiques
réduction des îlots de chaleur captation
des pluies filtration des polluants
refuge de biodiversité par exemple
social ensuite car lutter contre
l'artificialisation déraisonnée s'est
limitée l'étalement urbain et ses effets
négatifs sur le quotidien de ceux qui le
subissent difficultés d'accès au service
public insuffisance de commerce de
proximité ou encore absence de transport
collectif tout cela entraîne bien
souvent une paupérisation des ménages
concernés condamne à un usage contraint
de la voiture individuelle avec un coût
enruantal et financier économique enfin
car rapprocher les habitants des lieux
d'activité c'est vivifie un territoire
en favorisant
en favorisant pardon et facilitant les
interactions l'enjeu de la proximité est
en effet central il nous faut redonner
du lien entre habitat emploi et lieu de
consommation par des règles qui librages
notamment à l'échelle régionale grâce à
un redéploiement de certaines activités
petites industries artisanales et en
renforçant les polarités locales
raisonner notre façon d'artificialiser
c'est donc avant tout mieux construit en
optimisant les zones déjà
artificialisées il nous faut aller vers
une plus grande des densification une
réduction de la fragmentation
urbaine
surélévation sur élévation des bâtiments
transformation des sous-sols changements
d'usage mobilisation des bâtiments
vacants à des friches qui représentent
170 000 hectares à elle toute seule
autant de solutions à privilégier pour
optimiser l'existant attention il ne
s'agit pas ici d'entasser et d'étouffer
les populations dans les villes
cloisonnées mais de repenser notre façon
d'aménager qui a prévalu jusqu'à
aujourd'hui comment en travaillant sur
la qualité architecturale des bâtiments
à leur multi fonctionnalités en
répondant aux besoins d'espace et en
préservant les espaces verts de pleine
terre en développant les équipements et
les mobilités de proximité en réalisant
de vita véritables traverses qui doivent
être le support de mobilité active de
connexion entre les espaces urbains
denses et les espaces verts
périphériques ainsi que de véritables
écologiques qui agissent comme des
poumons des villes et des villages plus
compacts c'est l'assurance d'un accès
facilite à l'ensemble des besoins du
quotidien avec une moindre dépendance à
la voiture individuelle
entendons-nous bien je ne suis pas en
train d'opposer la ville à la rue
réalité chacun doit pouvoir préserver
les conditions de son attractivité
cependant une fois insister sur la
nécessité de renforcer la planification
de l'aménagement de nos toiles à
l'échelle régionale et locale
les gélules locaux savent que ces enjeux
sont fondamentaux ils ne sont pas
réfractaires à mieux prendre en compte
la lutte contre l'artificialisation
suite à l'adoption de la loi climat
résilience votée en 2021 ces élus
cependant exprimé des craintes quand un
éventuel impacte négatif sur le
développement et lactivité de leur
commune ces craintes nous les avons
tendues tout comme leurs besoins d'être
mieux accompagnés c'est pourquoi sans
revenir sur nos engagements la
proposition de loi d'initiative
sénatoriale qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui doit nous permettre
d'apporter des réponses concrètes avec
un meilleur encadrement à une
facilitation à la mise en oeuvre des
objectifs du zan dans ce texte nous nous
sommes fixés des objectifs forts et
ambitieux pour parvenir un juste
équilibre qui concilie protection de la
biodiversité et attractivité de nos
territoires notamment face aux enjeux de
la réindustrialisation nos débats en
commission ont permis d'évoquer des
enjeux majeurs que ce soit concernant
les projets d'intérêt national régional
ou intercommunal le droit minimal à
construire ou encore la prise en compte
des efforts passés de sobriété foncières
pour ce qui est du groupe démocrate nous
nous félicitons de l'AD
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je vais être bref
puisque l'essentiel de des réponses ça
c'est DG elle se fera tout au long de
des heures que nous allons passer
ensemble mais j'aimerais remercier le
député Le Fur d'avoir fait un plaidoyer
aussi vibrant pour le texte qui vous est
présenté
parce que après avoir dit que le risque
d'usane c'était de ne pas permettre la
réindustrialisation et de menacer la
ruralité il a finalement expliqué de
manière très cohérente la raison pour
laquelle il a retiré une mention de
rejet qui visait à mieux souligner la
nécessité d'avoir un texte comme celui
qui vous est présenté aujourd'hui
je voudrais simplement vous alerter sur
certaines facilités
le talent n'excluant pas le travail sur
ces sujets quand on regarde la réalité
objective des chiffres
on peut rendre Lausanne responsable de
beaucoup de choses mais il faut un
minimum d'objectivité pour être sûr de
pas se tromper de constat
nous avons aujourd'hui une crise du
logement
qui vaut dans plein de pays d'Europe
donc certains qui n'ont pas de zan parce
qu'on a une inflation des matériaux une
montée des taux d'intérêt qui complique
partout pour des raisons de pouvoir
d'achat une partie des difficultés et
donc ce serait une forme de facilité et
un risque d'erreur de diagnostic de
laisser penser
je me permets de dire que ça a été
évoqué par plusieurs orateurs ce matin
et de peur que ça revienne de manière
trop régulière pour nos deux débats je
préfère le dire de manière immédiate de
la même manière que laisser penser que
le âne voudrait dire la fin de la maison
individuelle ce serait là aussi une
caricature qui ne correspond pas à la
réalité
tenir une trajectoire foncière de
division par deux ça veut juste dire
passer d'une moyenne de 8 pavillons
hectares à une moyenne de 16 pavillons
hectares dans plus de la moitié de
l'artificialisation c'est à dire des
jardins de 1200 a des jardins de 600
mètres carrés je parle d'une moyenne
parce que je pourrais faire exactement
la même chose avec la moyenne des
jardins à plus de 2500 m² puisqu'il y en
a également nous n'imposons pas un
modèle nous nous inscrivons dans une
trajectoire de sobriété
laisser penser qu'il s'agiraient d'un
texte de décroissance ça va à la fois
l'encontre de la réalité des chiffres
qui sont devant nous et ça va là aussi
je le redis à l'encontre de la réflexion
que nous devons avoir sur ce qu'est la
réalité de notre patrimoine
nos paysages nos forêts nos sols nos
espaces agricoles c'est une partie de
nos biens communs et si tu ne partie de
ce qui nous permet précisément d'avoir
ces espaces de développement d'avoir
cette vitalité touristique d'avoir cette
réalité d'atouts pour notre pays alors
j'ai bien noté la multiplicité des
champs sur lesquels nous aurions à
discuter entre ceux qui considèrent que
la liste des grands projets d'envergure
nationale serait trop large ceux qui la
considèrent comme étant trop restrictive
ce qui souhaite qu'on se préoccupe des
territoires littoraux des territoires de
montagne et je pourrais multiplier les
propos qui ont été tenus mesdames et
messieurs les députés notre intention et
ça je l'ai entendu sur tous ces bancs
c'est à la fois de tenir cet objectif de
sobriété foncière et de redonner de la
souplesse en faisant confiance aux élus
de terrain c'est ce qui est au cœur du
texte c'est ce qui est au cœur de toute
une partie des dispositifs et
précisément
je me réjouis que nous n'ayons pas été
au terme d'une motion qui aurait
consisté à laisser penser que le droit
existant est préférable aux adaptations
qui vont vous être présentées sur
lesquelles le travail en commission a
déjà été extrêmement conséquent et sur
lequel nous allons pouvoir tout au long
des heures qui viennent faire en sorte
de faire oeuvres utile pour concilier
cette ambition et le pragmatisme dans sa
mise en œuvre
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à monsieur le Président de la Commission
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre madame la
vice-présidente monsieur les rapporteurs
chers collègues nous débutons l'examen
des articles sur cette proposition là
qui a fait l'objet de plus de 600
amendements c'est beaucoup et je
souhaiterais que l'examen des articles
débutent comme cela est prévu aux
articles premiers et 2 mais pour que les
débats essentiels puissent se tenir en
présence du plus grand nombre d'entre
nous une fois que nous aurons achevé
l'examen des additionnels après deux il
me semble nécessaire d'appeler en
priorité les deux articles ayant suscité
le plus de discussions en commission à
savoir l'article 4 sur les projets
d'ampleur national et l'article 7 sur la
garantie rurale et donc en application
de l'article 95 alinéa 4 de notre
règlement je demande l'examen en
priorité des articles 4 et 7 de la
proposition de loi ainsi que des
amendements portant articles
additionnels avant ou après chacun de
ces deux articles je vous remercie
madame la Présidente